Thanks to its acquisition of 3Lateral, Epic has advanced its digital human initiative through the creation of MetaHumans.
The latest version of MetaHuman Creator is now embedded into Unreal Engine 5.6 for better functionality and project integration.
This allows for faster turnaround times and better ease of use.
Updates to LiveLink Face and MetaHuman Animator allow you to take advantage of your iOS device to stream data directly into Unreal with your phone in real time.
These tools, when combined with regular body motion capture devices, will allow users to animate humans on an unprecedented level.
For traditional-based DCC animators working in Maya, Maya LiveLink is now available on the Autodesk website.
This tool will allow users to connect both applications together to take advantage of their Maya skill sets while simultaneously seeing animation and rendered content in Unreal.
As of the creation of this slide deck, Maya LiveLink currently supports Unreal Engine 5.5.4.
Another important tool for any animator or cinematographer's arsenal is Unreal ViewCam.
This tool leverages an iPhone or an iPad to transmit position and rotational data via LiveLink to drive the camera in real time.
This capability allows the user to capture that handheld feel, or when paired with some sort of camera rig, the user can create more controlled shots.
For those of you worried about not having an Apple product, ViewCam is now available for Android.
It's required that you use Unreal Engine 5.4 or later and have an Android device 7 or greater with the Unreal ViewCam app installed.
There are also a number of fantastic third-party companies that provide excellent motion capture, animation, and production tools for Unreal.
Many of their software products or plugins can be found on FAB.
If you're looking for mocap solutions or related tools, you have plenty of options to choose from.
Thanks for watching.